my opponent tonight co-wrote the book
lean in was a writer for shows like The
Simpsons and Late Night with David
Letterman and has written jokes for
Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton Wow not
many writers can transition from comedy
to horror that successfully Nell
Scoville
now welcome of course valid a touch in
this book here you talk a lot about
being the only female writer in a
writers room and help him break the
glass ceiling can I just ask you to do
me a favor
before we continue so yeah president
Trump comes out he attacks Jim Comey for
his book and the book becomes the
bestseller right so I write this book I
I honestly thought people would attack
me and they've been so nice they say
it's funny true they love it yeah and it
would really help to create some
controversy so if you wouldn't mind
could you just call me a no-talent whore
please
this feels like it's wrapped I'm your
guest no example I know
are you are you times up in me right now
is that what's going on is throughout
history when women spoke up men tried to
silence them and I come out with this
book and at the one moment when men are
thinking twice about you know telling
women were terrible and and should make
them sandwiches see on the one hand like
I want to satisfy your demand I'm not
always great at satisfying women if I'm
being quite honest with you you can do
it Jordan just Nell I'm afraid I've
looked at your book and you're say it a
talentless whore I really am if that can
help sell some books please I know it
takes a man to sell books so use me
however you can but but in all
seriousness you are fairly talentless
and I'm attractive in any way yeah I
like form so you wrote this all by your
woman self is that what you're telling
me
I am yeah yeah yeah well so why is it
hard to get these women into these
writers rooms in fact let me say this
you right now you are trying one of your
jobs is to try to help get women into
writers rooms is that correct yes what
is mission not a job it's a mission yeah
okay okay your mission is to do that why
isn't there a man doing that thing for
people like me well there there have
been their names are David Letterman Jay
Leno Johnny Carson you just were born at
the wrong time Jordan yes I keep saying
that I should have been born 20 years
earlier right you've also written for
Hillary Clinton and Barack Obama what
was it like writing for humor for people
like that with no sense of humor
well I actually disagree and I think
President Obama especially had an
incredible sense of humor he had great
delivery that's what I have this this is
this is a joke you wrote that he did not
read is that correct and this would be
good examples of how untalented I am
great yeah let let me let me read some
of this then I turned 50 while in office
which meant I had to have my first
colonoscopy and guess what they found
Mitch McConnell that guy could obstruct
anything yeah I see what you're doing
there you're you're implying that Mitch
McConnell was up the president's ass
yeah maybe that's why he didn't do the
job yes I'm gonna say that
that I do like now tell me something I
already know
can I tell you two things please okay
the first is that your forehead takes up
as much space as the rest of your face
and
but you knew that and you have more and
the second is that half of your writing
staff is female so high five
oh that's that's that's Viacom mandated
[Applause]
her book is called just the funny parts
now Scovel
[Music]